la presidenta de Honduras
Xiomara Castro firmó el protocolo para
sellar la instalación de una misión
internacional de lucha contra la
corrupción y la impunidad en Honduras en
la sede de las Naciones Unidas la
mandataria informó a través de su cuenta
oficial de Twitter y abro comillas junto
al secretario general de las Naciones
Unidas instalaremos una Sisi
independiente y justa Asimismo la
mandataria dijo que han logrado acuerdos
para la selección de expertos que
trabajarán y que además investigarán las
redes de corrupción públicos y privadas
de alto impacto que según la mandataria
han saqueado el país la traída de la
Sisi a Honduras fue una de las promesas
de campaña más importantes de la
presidenta Castro quien se comprometió a
luchar frontalmente contra la corrupción
anteriormente existía en el país
también una misión internacional de
lucha contra la corrupción la Maxi sin
embargo en enero del 2020 y gracias a
que el expresidente Juan Orlando
Hernández se negó a extender este
convenio con la oea esta organización
tuvo que marcharse del país sin embargo
sus investigaciones fueron de alto
impacto ya que gracias a ellas muchos
diputados políticos y empresarios fueron
llevados a la justicia hondureña